[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
bereits bekommen an diesem freitagabend
und herne ist das halbfinal-aus von
sphärisch gleich vorne
der hamburger musste verletzt aufgeben
guten abend von mir jetzt schauen wir
erstmal auf die großen themen heute
schweres zugunglück bei garmisch
partenkirchen eine regionalbahnen gleis
vier menschen sterben 30 werden verletzt
100 tage ukraine krieg die russische
armee steht offenbar kurz davor die
gesamte region luhansk einzunehmen
wichtige abstimmungen der bundestag
beschließt das 100 milliarden euro
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr und
der mindestlohn steigt auf 12 euro
es ist der beginn der pfingstferien in
bayern als der regional express
entgleist mindestens vier menschen
kommen dabei ums leben 30 menschen
werden verletzt davon müssen 15 in
krankenhäuser gebracht werden und das
kannst du stolz und bayerns
ministerpräsident müller sprachen den
angehörigen und verletzten ihr mitgefühl
aus noch immer sind die rettungskräfte
im großeinsatz der zug war von garmisch
partenkirchen richtung münchen unterwegs
kurz nach dem start und leisten auf der
regionalbahnstrecke bei burg rhein
mehrere waggons sibylle bassler die
menschen stehen unter schock irren umher
kurz zuvor ist der voll besetzte
regionalzug aus garmisch partenkirchen
in richtung münchen entgleist mehrere
waggons sind umgekippt einige die
böschung hinabgefallen mindestens vier
menschen sind ums leben gekommen
es gibt zahlreiche verletzte die ursache
für das unglück noch ungeklärt die
ermittler sind jetzt im hirn
unfallstelle zu gange um die ersten
erkenntnisse zu sammeln um dann
möglichst schnell die unfallursache
klären zu können ein großaufgebot an
feuerwehr notärzte polizei ist im
einsatz
nur fünf minuten nach dem notruf waren
die ersten rettungskräfte vor ort an
bord des regionalzugs waren auch
soldaten der bundeswehr die soforthilfe
leisten die haben uns sehr stark
unterstützt die haben uns die verletzten
über die fed die am fenster
eingeschlagen die fenster raus gemacht
und die feuerwehr konnte steckleitern 30
ins wageninnere steigen mit
rettungsgeräten konnten die
einsatzkräfte die verletzten fahrgäste
darunter auch schwerverletzte bergen das
sind auch kinder dabei ja leider also
sind alle altersgruppen betroffen die
verletzten wurden in die umliegenden
krankenhäuser gebracht wie ermittler
gehen davon aus dass es möglicherweise
noch weitere opfer gibt es ist auch
leider nicht uns ausgeschlossen dass
unter den trümmern noch weitere
todesopfer zu finden sind die arbeiten
an der unglücksstelle in borken dauern
am abend weiter an
na dann an der unglücksstelle ist jutta
sonne wald für uns jutta wie läuft denn
gerade hinter die bergung und was weißt
du neues darüber was passiert ist
als die rettungskräfte die einsatzkräfte
haben alle verletzten fahrgäste bergen
können aus den wracks viel tote gab es
insgesamt eine person ist auf dem weg
ins krankenhaus gestorben
und mindestens noch drei personen sollen
unter dem wrack sich noch befinden die
müssen die rettungskräfte jetzt noch
bergen dazu müssen diese tonnenschweren
waggons noch angehoben werden wie es zu
dem unglück kam das weiß man immer noch
nicht die polizei schließt zumindest auf
das aus dass es eine kollision gab denn
es handelt sich hier um eine eingleisige
strecke das sieht man auch auf den
luftaufnahmen der polizei und es gibt
hier auch keine weichen der zugführer
lokführer hat überlebt er ist im
krankenhaus und weiß aber nicht in
welchem zustand der ist deswegen kann
man jedoch noch nicht befragen aber laut
eines bahnsprechers auch hier vor ort
hat er angeblich kein rotes waren signal
überfahren also insofern das sind die
dinge die man weiß und die ermittlungen
laufen jetzt durch eine sonde
ermittlungsteam auf hochtouren hier und
sie werden das weiter für uns beobachten
dankeschön jutta sonne wald
denken wir jetzt in die ukraine genau
100 tage ist der beginn des krieges her
wie viele opfer der krieg bisher
gefordert hat es schwer einzuschätzen
die vereinten nationen haben bisher den
tod von mindestens 4.000 100 getöteten
zivilistinnen und zivilisten bestätigt
aber dass so ein menschenrechtsbüro geht
von deutlich höheren zahlen aus zurzeit
wird vor allem um den osten des landes
gekämpft wir fragen gleich unseren
reporter vor ort nach einer einschätzung
nach 100 tagen krieg wir blicken aber
jetzt erst einmal kurz zurück die
angriffe der russischen truppen hier mit
dunklem orange eingezeichnet beginnen am
24 februar auf breiter front den
geplanten schnellen vormarsch auf die
hauptstadt kiew können die ukraine
zurückschlagen russland sieht sich hier
anfang april zurück ändert die strategie
und konzentriert sich auf den osten und
süden mario ball fällt nach heftigen
widerstand im mai jetzt kämpft sich die
russische armee langsamen donners vor
wie publicity berichtet
auf panzern demonstrieren sie ihre macht
russische kämpfer in der region luhansk
die sie inzwischen fast vollständig
unter ihrer kontrolle haben und moskaus
truppen rücken immer weiter vor
besonders umkämpft ist die stadt sehr
piero donetsk hunderte zivilisten sollen
hier in einer chemiefabrik zuflucht
gesucht haben
ukrainische truppen verteidigen die
stadt mit hilfe von fremden legionären
der britische geheimdienst geht davon
aus dass russland bald den gesamten
donnerstag seiner kontrolle haben wird
der ukrainische botschafter in
deutschland will das nicht hinnehmen
mehr noch er drängt auf eine
rückeroberung der krim wir werden auf
die krimi verzichten das ist klar die
frage ist wann wir sind realistisch
gesehen mit welcher übermacht russland
diesen angriffs und vernichtungskrieg
wird russlands armee nutzt tag 100
seines angriffskriegs für symbolik
veröffentlicht diese bilder von
panzerhaubitzen und reichlich munition
die botschaft wir sind weiter
kampfbereit
symbolik auch in kiew in der innenstadt
stellen sie erbeutetes russisches
kriegsgerät aus der präsident gibt sich
siegessicher wir verteidigen die ukraine
seit 100 tagen der sieg wird unser sein
ruhm der ukraine
100 tage krieg zehntausende menschen so
selensky sind bislang ums leben gekommen
wie hier in mariupol sind die friedhöfe
oft zu klein geworden tausende tote
tausende schicksale aber an den gräbern
stehen meist nicht einmal die namen
sondern nur nummern
und in der ukraine ist unser reporter
johannes hano johannes die ukraine werde
es gerade gesehen gibt sich also weiter
siegessicher
wie ist das einzuschätzen nach 100 tagen
krieg
präsidentiellen ski weiß natürlich dass
er seinen bürgerinnen bürgern genau eine
solche antwort schuldet die leute wollen
hier diesen krieg gewinnen das ist
völlig klar niemand mag sich vorstellen
dass man gegen russland verliert mario
pohl champion all das habe gezeigt was
beim russischen sieg passieren würde
nämlich die völlige auslöschung und
zerstörung der ukraine als nation und
dagegen will sich jeder wirklich mit
hand und fuß dagegen stemmen der
präsident hat aber auch gesagt dass man
diesen krieg nicht gewinnen kann man
habe verfüge darüber nicht über die
nötigen waffen um diesen krieg hier zu
gewinnen und deswegen macht er immer
wieder druck auch die westlichen
verbündeten man brauche diese waffen
schwere waffen luftabwehrsysteme um
diesen krieg am ende auch gewinnen zu
können die sind nicht da es fehlt ja
also an waffen und nicht an der moral
auch nach 100 tagen sind die leute ihr
völlig kampfbereit und jeder möchte hier
sofort die russen aus dem land bringen
aus der ukraine johannes hano dankeschön
seit gestern ist der ukrainische
parlamentspräsidenten russlands der fand
stuck zu gast in berlin heute traf er
bundeskanzler scholz zu einem sehr
angenehmen gespräch ließ später aus dem
kanzleramt zum inhalt wurde nichts
bekannt aber wie angekündigt hat der
fand jörg scholz offenbar nach kiew
eingeladen was dieser freundlich zur
kenntnis genommen habe so ein
regierungssprecher ob es inzwischen
reisepläne gibt ist nicht bekannt
russland hat die ukrainische häfen
blockiert so dass das land kam noch
getreide exportieren kann mit weltweiten
folgen der tschad hat heute bereits
einen ernährungs notstand ausgerufen der
präsident der afrikanischen union mag
israel war jetzt beim russischen
präsidenten putin in sotschi zu besuch
und forderte ein ende der blockade über
die befürchtete hungerkatastrophe
berichtet luden liners die ukraine
fruchtbare böden üppige erträge der
brotkorb europas dann kam der krieg die
ernte fällt nun deutlich niedriger aus
auf geradezu dramatische weise aber
bricht der getreideexport 1
man geht davon aus dass gegenwärtig mehr
als 20 millionen tonnen getreide in der
ukraine blockiert sind die eigentlich
exportiert werden könnten die aber nicht
die uhr gerade verlassen können weil
russland die häfen blockiert es klemmt
vor allem hier in odessa dem mit abstand
wichtigsten experten für getreide aus
der ukraine
die folgen für die welternährung könnten
verheerend sein bislang versorgte die
ukraine mit ihrem getreide weite teile
der welt
bevölkerungsreiche länder wie ägypten
und indonesien sind besonders abhängig
und droht womöglich eine eine
kernschmelze
der nahrungs systeme weil diese diese
effekte
eingeschränkte export horten sich so
addieren dass viele staaten die auf
importe angewiesen sind das einfach
nicht mehr leisten können ägypten mit
seinen 100 millionen einwohnern ist
besonders hart getroffen das land
versucht gerade in aller eile eigene
ernteerträge zu steigern
vor allem in afrika ist die abhängigkeit
von weizen aus der ukraine und russland
groß dazu kommt wegen der korona krise
sind die reserven vieler staaten
komplett aufgebraucht ist kann schon
dazu führen dass wir das wir grausame
bilder sehen werden von von vielen um
handel und sterbenden menschen ein
erster versuch die blockade der helfen
doch noch zu lockern soll nächste woche
stattfinden die türkei und russland
wollen über die öffnung eines korridors
für ukrainische getreideexporte
verhandeln
und die blockade ukrainischer
lebensmittelexporte dich russland ist
auch thema beim zdf heute live und 1930
in der zdf- heute- app auf youtube und
facebook
eine marode bundeswehr und kein geld für
die sanierung damit soll schluss sein
nach langem hin und her hat der
bundestag den weg frei gemacht für die
von kanzler scholz versprochene
zeitenwende mit zwei drittel mehrheit
bewilligt das sondervermögen bundeswehr
100 milliarden euro für eine ja wirklich
lange einkaufsliste die reicht von
tarnkappen kampfjets bis zu soldaten
stiefeln außerdem 50,4 milliarden euro
aus dem regulären haushalt 2022 für den
es ebenfalls grünes licht gab david
gebert berichtet als der kanzler sein
kärtchen in die urne steckt scheint er
sich der späteren breiten mehrheit im
bundestag gewiss für massive aufrüstung
der bundeswehr die scholz zeitenwende
nennt nach jahren der miss und
mangelwirtschaft hubschrauber die nicht
fliegen u boote die nicht fahren
mangelnde ausrüstung blank stehe die
bundeswehr da hieß es selbst von top
militärs nun soll das alles anders
werden
wurde die bundeswehr vernachlässigt und
heruntergewirtschaftet ich höre ganz oft
wir haben das nicht wir haben davon zu
wenig es ist verbraucht es defekt und
damit muss endlich schluss sein um das
sogenannte sondervermögen im grundgesetz
zu verankern brauchte die ampel stimmen
aus der union die grünen wollten daraus
mittel etwa in cyber sicherheit stecken
dagegen hatte sich die union gestimmt
die grünen haben ihre forderung
aufgegeben das geld an anderer stelle
für andere ministerien und für andere
aufgaben zu verwenden aufgegeben ich
fand sie vor ein ganz süßer dobrindt
dass sie so gesagt haben alle haben sich
bewegt nur wir nicht wenn sie dass wir
ihr ego brauchen bitte schön die 100
milliarden sondervermögen quasi
ausgegliederte neue schulden dieser
sonderform ja er wird auch mit
kreditermächtigungen aufgestellt die
alternativen wären wirtschaftlich in
dieser kritischen phase schlechter es
braucht diese grundgesetzänderung nicht
um der bundeswehr ihr geld zu geben die
afg kritisiert die art der finanzierung
sondervermögen die linke neue
militärausgaben generell
sondern unser steuergeld verbrennung sie
haben unfähigen minister der union jetzt
von der spd gehabt das ist die ursache
von modernen kampfjets bis zu neuen
funkgeräten und stiefeln die
bundesregierung wird nun massiv in die
landes- und bündnisverteidigung
investieren
und auch das hat der bundestag
beschlossen
zum ersten juli steigen die renten
deutlich im westen um 5,35 prozent und
im osten um 6,12 prozent und für
mini-jobs gilt eine neue
einkommensgrenze ab oktober wird sie von
derzeit 450 auf 520 euro angehoben
außerdem steigt der mindestlohn auf 12
euro ab dem ersten oktober
dafür stimmten die koalition und die
linken union und fdp enthielten sich der
arbeitgeberverband bda spricht von einem
angriff auf die tarifautonomie
da die höhe des mindestlohns
normalerweise von arbeitgebern und
gewerkschaften ausgehandelt wird die spd
löst mit dem 12 euro mindestlohn eines
ihrer zentralen wahlkampfversprechen ein
oder spiekermann berichtet
friseurteam stephanie speer im bezirk
berlin mitte es sind schwere zeiten erst
corona jetzt inflation trotzdem ist die
chefin froh dass es einen höheren
mindestlohn geben wird ist mir sehr
wichtig dass ich die arbeit an erkenne
auch in form von lohn und ich finde es
auch gut dass das jetzt alle zahlen
müssen dass das fix ist der
gesetzentwurf kommt von arbeitsminister
hubertus heil die ampel regierung hatte
in ihrem koalitionsvertrag vereinbart
den mindestlohn einmalig auf 12 euro zu
erhöhen anfang oktober tritt die
anhebung in kraft das ist für viele
menschen für sechs millionen menschen in
deutschland vor einigen willst du viele
frauen und für viele beschäftigte in
ostdeutschland glücklicherweise der
größte rundfunk in ihrem leben von 2
die union enthält sich heute bei der
abstimmung spricht von zu vielen
bürokratischen hürden obwohl sie selbst
im jüngsten landtagswahlkämpfen für die
anhebung des mindestlohns geworben hatte
wir stehen nicht gegen einen mindestlohn
von 12 euro aber wir erreichen nicht die
hand für die entmündigung der
sozialpartner der höhere mindestlohn ist
eine politische entscheidung und nicht
die der eigentlich zuständigen
mindestlohn-kommission das berliner
friseur team glaubt konkurrenzfähig
bleiben zu können die anhebung sei nötig
weil ich glaube unter dem mindestlohn
kann man gar nicht leben das geht nicht
der mindestlohn von 12 euro kommt in
zeiten deutlich steigender preise
seit 70 jahren sitzt die britische queen
auf dem thron das wird auf der insel
groß gefeiert heute mit einem
dankgottesdienst in london und er wurde
zu einem stelldichein prominenter
besucherinnen und besucher nur eine die
fete und das war die jubel jahren selbst
queen elizabeth die zweite sagte wegen
unwohlseins ihre teilnahme ab der
zimmermann
vergebens hatte die menge auf die queen
gehofft widerstreben zu hieß es aus dem
palast musste die tiefgläubige
monarchien darauf verzichten am
gottesdienst ins imports teilzunehmen
der gestrige lange tag war dann wohl
doch etwas zu anstrengend gewesen für
die 96 jährige
heute also ohne sie aber doch mit viel
prominenz
der umstrittene premier wurde bei seiner
ankunft ausgebuht mit spannung erwartet
der auftritt von harry und mägen der
erste in london seit die beiden nicht
mehr zu den aktiven mitgliedern der
königsfamilie gehören zum schluss der
künftige könig prinz charles in
vertretung seiner mutter können die
briten sich vorstellen dass er sie eines
tages ganz ersetzen wird
[Musik]
mona hier ist so gut für uns ich glaube
wir werden uns auch an charts gewöhnen
ich würde natürlich immer noch die
monarchie unterstützen aber ich muss
zugeben ich bin ein fan der queen und
nicht so sehr ein fan der monarchie
thema des gottesdienstes waren
pflichtbewusstsein und ausdauer der
queen der erzbischof von york verglich
die 70 jahre regentschaft von elisabeth
der zweiten mit einem sehr langen ritt
und schickte grüße gerne windsor wo er
die jubilarin am fernseher wusste
es tut uns leid dass sie nicht mit uns
sein können an diesem morgen aber wir
sind glücklich dass sie immer noch fest
im sattel sitzen
nicht fest genug als dass sie bei allen
feierlichkeiten zu ihren ehren
teilnehmen könnte doch spätestens
sonntag so hoffen die königstreuen
briten wird sie ihnen noch einmal vom
balkon zu winken
und jetzt kommen wir zuerst mit dem
albtraum jedes sportlers bei den french
open norbert da hat sich alexander
zverev so verletzt im halbfinale gegen
rafael nadal dass er aufgeben musste er
leider aus der traum vom endspiel am
sonntag in paris böse umgeknickt zum
ende des zweiten satzes ist ja bis dahin
hatte sich der olympiasieger mit dem
spanier einen hochklassigen zweikampf
geliefert mit leichten vorteilen für
nadal
dieses erste halbfinale in paris konnte
tragischer kaum enden in einem match
zwar nahezu gleichwertiger gegner
verdrehte sich alexander zverev beim
stande von 6 6 im zweiten satz
fürchterlich den rechten fuß und sein
lautes schreien vor schmerz ließ ahnen
dass es eine sehr schwere verletzung
sein würde
ihn dort beiden zu sehen ist ein
brutaler moment ich kann ihm nur das
beste wünschen
bis zu den tragischen unfall war es ein
hochklassiges halbfinale in dem rafael
nadal den tie break im ersten satz
denkbar knapp gewonnen hatte und
ballwechsel wie dieser hier die pariser
tennisfans begeisterten
nadal wird nun am sonntag im finale
seinen vierzehnten titel bei den french
open anstreben während alexander zverev
seine tennis träume vorerst begraben
muss
zehnmal ddr meister 2001 feierte der sc
magdeburg die erste deutsche
meisterschaft gestern abend und damit 21
jahre später war es wieder soweit der
ist sie gewann daheim gegen balingen
weilstetten mit 31 zu setzen 20 und
sicherte sich damit vorzeitig den titel
nach dem abpfiff grenzenloser jubel in
und außerhalb der halle ein feiertag
nicht nur für eine stadt sondern für
eine ganze region
morgen das erste nations league spiel
der dfb-auswahl in bologna gegen
europameister italien bis auf bvb
stürmer marco reus reist der komplette
25 köpfige kader an vier tage lang haben
sie trainiert und automatismen
einstudiert das italien-spiel eine
standortbestimmung die hansi flick
herbeigesehnt hat grundsätzlich glaube
ich dass jeder ja sehr motiviert er ist
im ersten spiel the nations league
wir haben das bestmögliche ergebnis zu
holen und von daher
glaube ich glaube ich einfach dass es
für unsere gutes spiel wird
überraschungen in der startelf sind eher
nicht zu erwarten mit welchem personal
er plant ließ league allerdings offen
aktuell warnt der deutsche wetterdienst
vor schweren gewittern in bayern mehr
zum wetter gleich von katja honnefer das
heute-journal können sie um 22 uhr sehen
mit christian sievers auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend die ersten gewitter gab es
schon heute mittag über baden
württemberg und am nachmittag gab es
dann mehr gewitter aus den alpen heraus
und schauer und gewitter begleiten uns
auch durch die nacht sie ziehen weiter
in richtung osten und bis morgen früh
werden sie deutschlands ostwärts
verlassen haben von diesen ganzen
twitter bekommen sie in norddeutschland
in der nacht gar nichts mit da ist es
trocken zum teil auch klar und da bleibt
es bei 12 bis 6 grad am kühlsten milder
bleibt die nacht unter den schauer und
gewitterwolken in süddeutschland bei 16
bis 13 grad morgen erwarten uns im
norden an der küste so 16 bis 20 grad
sonst und des 21 bis 27 grad am
oberrhein geht sogar bis 29 grad laufen
das wird der freundlichste tag des
langen pfingstwochenendes meist gibt es
nämlich viel sonnenschein über den
mittelgebirgen und richtung ostbayern
westlich des rheins oder auch im
schwarzwald kannst du dann am nachmittag
mal ein paar schauer oder gewitter geben
und dann kommt der pfingstsonntag und
damit breiten sich unwetter von westen
aus und die erreichen fast ganz
deutschland nur hier nordöstlich der
elbe bleibt es den pfingstsonntag über
noch freundlich danach beruhigt sich das
wetter ganz langsam guten abend